you've got your values there I hope can
we have a look what did we get for this
orange one here I mean you can almost
eyeball it country because we've chosen
run of one each time so what was the run
for this one that's right the difference
question I should say it's negative 5
and then negative 3 negative 1 then 1
then 3 and then 5 ok very good
now when you indeed your difference
questions over bigger triangles when
you're doing a width ever a run of -
what happened to your numbers what did
you get for example there's like a big
triangle go from here all the way down
to there what was your difference
question in that case said again with
half of the right so the rise in this
case is from from 5 down to negative 3
so that would be a rise of negative 8
and then you divided by the run which
was 2 so that gives me negative 4
there's like the average between these
right so if you can think this section
here from thinking about this is
negative 5 and the negative 3 as
compared to thinking of something
overall of negative 4 the negative 5 the
negative 3 that's more accurate isn't it
right but we could have got more
accurate than this right um I could have
said instead of doing you know one unit
this way this way this way this way this
is a big enough graph couldn't you have
done like run of say half a unit could
you totally could write in fact let's
let's find a spot over here maybe on the
right-hand side of the diagram right
let's go from 4 x equals 3 all the way
to x equals five can we draw some new
triangles on here and this time i only
want to go half a unit you're gonna need
to use your ruler for this one because I
actually want some measurements this
time so this is roughly what it's going
to look like I that looks like half to
me right so you're gonna have rectangles
it look like this and then this one's
gonna go across like so can you do that
for me
I'd like some more accurate triangles
here wait yes
can you see that yeah sort of like
jagged teeth if you like
[Music]
okay now as you're doing that here's the
thing I want you to notice let's let's
forget about units for a second I I
tried to get this right on your page but
those squares are not quiet one
centimeter I actually wanted a bigger so
you can see it easier let's all just use
our rulers and can you measure these
I've got one two three four
Heights four rises right can I get let's
see we've got four columns here coming
at you guys over on the Left can you
measure as accurate as you can maybe
give me you the nearest millimeter the
first one sorry so you can you guys do
the second one here in this column can
you do the third one I want the height
we all have the same width we all the
same run but the rise is what I'm after
and then lastly can you guys get me this
last one over here that should be enough
time for you who's measured out the
first triangle and its rise just give me
a number of millimeters on your rule up
why'd you get 1.8 its centimeters is
what I'm guessing yep great the second
triangle use your ruler sorry is it that
really does it go that far
yeah the second one 3.2 this one here
yeah that sounded a little more on the
money to me the third triangle 4.4 and
the last one really are you sure
does anyone see why I'm suspicious of
this so now what do you got have you got
a rule on there so what we're doing is
we're measuring halfway across this
between four and five right and then
we'll call it to here and this is the
distance we're measuring up here I'd be
very surprised if it was less than four
point four can we could we all have a
look at that I
five point three point six it's gotta be
one 4.0 4.6 it's got to be more it's
gotta be more okay
I'm just looking yeah interesting okay
so what you're noticing is right it's
covering increasing rises even for the
same run in other words it's getting
steeper and steeper and steeper which is
what you saw every time right for the
big triangles with a run of two for your
smaller ones with a run of one and then
for these guys with a run of a half you
could work out what your distance were
for each of those okay what if I wasn't
limited by you know what I could do with
a ruler what if I could make this run
like really really tiny this is me going
back to this guy right sorry I'm doing
this upside down this is me going back
to this model see this get rid of my
triangles now I can go in further I can
go in far enough because of wonderful
technology until such a point is right
oh I can see the difference right I can
see the discrepancy between like this is
my triangle and then the actual graph
but then if I go in further all I want
to try to do is make this value small
enough until like can your eyes tell the
difference my car like that triangle
might as well be the graph does this
make sense and the thing is I mean
here's here's the width of my triangle
on this one right but I can make this
smaller and smaller and smaller I have
no limits to what I can do
mathematically as opposed to the limits
that I have when I'm thinking about
physical measurement okay all right so
with that setting I want you to make a
new heading and that new heading is yeah
this is this is weird right the henny I
want you to make is sorry you could tell
me thank you
this idea of taking I should have I was
inviting trollee for that anyway so
that's fine of taking ever smaller
sections and say what if we can get more
accurate more accurate is it possible to
be infinitely accurate that is the
domain of what we call calculus question
negative negative
yes yep yep that's because were you
actually measuring just up distances
with a ruler whereas these are just all
with ones right does that make sense
whereas I think on your page it's like
one point I don't know well point three
or what pray for something like that
that's the reason for the different
numbers he'd be having a good time all
right so this difference question right
difference question what it tells us if
we can just write this result out again
right this big fraction this was the
rise you will call and what was the run
the run was just called H right what
this tells us is the gradient of those
are those sections that we saw before
right sorry I keep doing this right so
see these guys here the hypotenuse is
the hypotenuse because they joined
together two points on the curve right
geez no you may may or may not remember
this is a long time ago when you covered
this but when you are introduced to
circles in u7 you may have learned that
when you join two points on a circle do
you know what the name of this interval
is no it's actually a musical word this
is called a chord a chord you haven't
had to use this word for a long time so
it's okay if we won so it's a chord when
you join two points on this curvy thing
right well each of these hypothesis also
joins two points on this curvy object
right
so we also call them of chords okay so
what the chord is or rather what the
difference question is is the gradient
of the chord that's what you're working
on the gradient of the chord okay
now another word that's kind of it means
a different thing but it's sort of
analogous to it in this case if you took
this chord on this circle right and you
actually made it extend out so it didn't
start and stop at a particular point if
it just went on for infinity they don't
know what that's caught it's a bit
different
it's a line it's a line and it cuts the
circle to remember so cut off section
right is a sector but when you're using
this line we call it a secret or second
right it's it's that same word it means
cut okay so like a cross section is
where you cut the thing into like slices
right so it's the grading of the cord or
or the secret it's really the same thing
it's an object on line rather that cuts
through at the same time